[Music]
it's true that your Twitter account was
hacked by an impossible I know that
there's a while ago but how does that
even happen and it's the cruelest of
ironies my Twitter account was hacked
and it was hacked by a weight loss robot
so I sent out a tweet to all my
followers saying want to lose weight do
what I did and if you ever want to know
how quick your fans will turn on you is
send out a weight loss tweet when you're
a big guy yourself I got the angriest
responses like go to hell fat boy like
who are you telling me about losing
weight like no one knew I was hacked
right so they thought I was it was I was
giving people weight losses your fans
they're literally just turn on you like
that absolutely they turn on me just
today I said I was coming here and I had
a I had a big announcement to make that
I was I was gonna drop my album and my
new fragrance was gonna drop on
September 4th and people wrote back
what's your fragrance sweaty man that
was me now is this true that you uh
summer is not even over yet you've
already taken a big exotic trip where'd
you what you went to Monte Carlo what's
a Monte Carlo have you ever been to
Monte Carlo it is I stopped I like pass
through there once and they I just kept
moving as I didn't have it yeah it is
driven a Monte Carlo that's not possible
no I said a driven a money car Oh driven
any money never mind oh my god sorry
should've left it at the hog Andy ya
know I was in Monte Carlo I was on a
yacht okay first of all that was that
was a yacht yeah I was on yeah I've
never been on a yacht in my how'd you
get on a yacht I tell you okay yeah all
right he's not gone yeah I was like you
were a stowaway no no I was on a yacht
and we we would go we would dock in the
harbor and then go into town well one
night we were going to a place called
the billionaire's Club that's the name
of the club those places only existed in
movies no let's see your bank account
sir all right you're a millionaire you
can't get in anyway so we go into the
billionaire's Club and as we're walking
in sigh somebody said hey just FYI you
know there's a lot of prostitutes this
time of year in Monte Carlo so just be
on the lookout and this one guy was like
how will we know which one are the
prostitutes and I said they'll be the
ones talking to you and so we're
standing in the club literally this
beautiful woman in a red dress comes
walking over to me I'm like oh gosh here
we go and she's like hello and I said hi
how are you and she's like good I said
how where are you from Latvia like Czech
and then I said how long have you been
in town she's like a week jack thank you
how long are you gonna be here she's
like oh maybe one more week I'm like
Jack she's like well I just wanted to
come over and say um I'm a big fan of
Modern Family in Latvia like can you
just look over there and just high-five
me to those guys right over there right
now right yeah she was not she was just
a fan of Modern Family and I thought I
was she could have been a prostitute
who's a fan of Modern Family
maybe there's more to the story a story
with oh and one more thing are you a
[ __ ] well let's just say maybe I found
out oh and maybe you did that's right
[Laughter]
now Emmys coming up and once again you
were up against your three co-stars yeah
and you said at one point I'm just gonna
I want one of them to win this time how
do you feel about that statement well I
was kidding
absolutely did it no I want a 100% win
again I don't I'm not pulling for tie
Jesse or Edie no absolutely you know the
thing of it is is ty won last year I
want to hear before that and it'd be
awesome if I'd won or Jesse won but as
long as we keep it in the family like
we've been able to do so far that would
be awesome with me I've won at once and
that was amazing alright well best of
luck to ya